on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à mes
côtés marie roger biloa présidente du
groupe afrique international bonjour
marie roger vous n'y revenez du cameroun
merci d'être à nos côtés aujourd'hui
face à vous virginie hertz présentatrice
du magazine actuel sur france 24 dont
jean virginie c'est l'une des craintes
provoquées par la guerre en ukraine une
crise alimentaire aiguë stimulée par les
hausses de prix et surtout la pénurie de
céréales retenue dans les ports en
ukraine le blocus qui exerce
actuellement la russie paralyse le
trafic maritime la faute aux occidentaux
estiment moscou écouter sergueï lavrov
les pays occidentaux qui ont créé
beaucoup de problèmes superficiel en
fermant leurs ports aux navires us en
perturbant les chaînes logistiques et
financières doivent sérieusement
réfléchir à ce qui est le plus important
pour eux soit faire de la communication
sur la question de la sécurité
alimentaire soit prendre des mesures
concrètes pour résoudre ce problème
virginie sur quoi se fonde le
raisonnement de sergueï lavrov les
occidentaux ont une responsabilité alors
raisonnement ça sincèrement je ne peux
pas suivre le raisonnement de sergueï
lavrov par contre je peux peut-être
décrypter ses objectifs quand il dit ça
vous savez que depuis le début du
conflit on est quand même dans une
distorsion de réalité l'érudit ce qu'ils
attaquent la l'ukraine pour des jeunes a
dit fier et là tout d'un coup ils vont
dire bah voilà finalement cédé
occidentaux qui propose qui provoque
cette crise alimentaire alors que la
femme dans la haine l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises les russes utilisent le blé
comme une arme de rigueur j'y serai pas
aussi moi mais ce qui est clair c'est
qu'il utilise comme un moyen de pression
et la semaine dernière d'ailleurs très
clairement ils ont dit qu'ils sont prêts
à faciliter l'exportation des céréales
ukrainienne en échange de la levée des
sanctions sur leurs propres exportations
céréalières notamment à eux donc
vraiment si on est dans un marchandage
dans une négociation et voilà peut-être
pas le raisonnement de sergueï lavrov
mais en tout cas son objectif maillot
rouge il la russie at elle raison de
renvoyer la balle aux occidentaux
comment les les premiers concernés
finalement par ce cri si elle advient
c'est à dire les pays du continent
africain perçoit fille la situation et
bien c est toujours par rossel parce que
les pays africains n'ont pas très envie
de condamner la russie certains suivent
même le point de vue russe en en
considérant que la russie a été forcé de
faire cette guerre qu'elle était acculé
et que tout ce qui se passe maintenant
est de la faute des occidentaux mais
cela dit tout le monde est préoccupé par
aller la pénurie alimentaire et surtout
la famille qui s'annonce et il est déjà
perceptible les effets sur les prix et
les tensions sur certaines certains
aliments sont déjà perçus sont déjà
perceptibles je dirais même ils étaient
déjà avant parce qu'on oublie souvent de
rappeler que le coc vide avait déjà
rendu la situation très très difficile
les chaînes d'approvisionnement était
déjà très perturbé et il y avait déjà
des pénuries à l'époque et au moment où
on pense qu'on en sort petit à petit on
blaguait redon cela la guerre asus
aggraver la situation qui était déjà
assez tendu et donc elle les réflexions
évidemment c'est comment devenir
autonome
évidemment comment utiliser des céréales
qui sont cons produits localement mais
on sait que les productions sont
insuffisantes mais bon et qu'il faudrait
effectivement une vraie volonté
politique et pousser cet agenda surtout
que
en afrique à peu près 40 pour cent de la
population dépend à plus de la moitié de
la production russe est écrit
ukrainienne des céréales mais au-delà de
ça quand même le problème c'est
qu'on regarde cette pénurie qui va
arriver on est comme tétanisée et est ce
que est ce qu'on ne faut pas revenir aux
fondamentaux c'est de dire cette guerre
comment faire pour l'arrêter parce que
là maintenant ce qu'on voit c'est rien
par rapport à ce qu'il ya l'année
prochaine on manque d'estimé qu'on a ça
mais dompter toutes les médiations
auprès de réduire poutine les appels de
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
l'union africaine et son président macky
sall clairement depuis maintenant des
semaines ça a commencé à au forum de
davos là il était invité au sommet d'une
union européenne de façon virtuelle dit
finalement il condamne pas la russie
condamne pas le crès il essaye de rester
au dessus il dit quel que soit le
conflit l'alertent ont levé des
solutions l'un d'eux ou vont les
solutions qu est la voie la plus que de
paix des solutions justes pour débloquer
la situation justement et débloquer les
céréales alors un acteur pourrait bien
débloquer la situation des génisses et
la turquie oui absolument alors la
turquie on le sait une position
intermédiaire dans ce conflit depuis le
début la turquie qui vend des drones aux
ukrainiens mais en même temps qu'ils
gardent bonnes relations avec les russes
dont les turcs aux dépens de nantes
notamment pour pour le pour le gaz les
autorités turques qui se sont proposés
comme intermédiaires dans ce conflit et
qui justement sur sept ce problème des
céréales peuvent jouer éventuellement un
rôle parce que c'est un pays la turquie
riverains de la mer noire qui a un droit
de regard si ce n'est de contrôle sur
les sur les d 3 et qui pourrait jouer un
rôle d'ailleurs vladimir poutine a dit
qu' il était d'accord pour travailler
ensemble avec le président r douanes
pour trouver une solution la turquie
pourrait mettre en place des corridors
sécurisés par exemple ou faire des des
escortes en tout cas tout ça devrait
être discutée prochainement et sergueï
lavrov le chef de la diplomatie russe
doit se rendre le 8 juin prochain en
turquie faut-il faire confiance à air de
gamme marie rose à ton choix et cathy
lui est nécessaire ce moment est ce
qu'on a vraiment le choix et tout ce
qu'on voit le président de chancelier
allemand était à au sénégal et en
afrique a fait une petite tournée
africaine il ya quelques jours et il a
dit par exemple au sénégal qu'ils ont
que l'allemagne allait travailler à
trouver une solution pour que les
céréales qui sont bloqués en ukraine
plus être acheminés vers donc les
clients bon mais même cette solution là
on nous dit que si ça marchait vraiment
très bien c'est à peine 20% de ce qui
bloquait en ukraine qu il faut sortir
donc en soit je crois que on peut
regarder disons la situation dans les
détails qui peut faire quoi là la
turquie
mais je crois que il faut faire tomber
des tabous maintenant par rapport à la
guerre qui doit s'arrêter et à quel prix
qu'est ce que doit concéder l'ukraine
qu'est ce que doit concéder la russie
est vraiment parler parce que on a tout
le monde me dit aujourd'hui ni la russie
ni l'ukraine sont prêts à entendre quoi
que ce soit il est là il la russie n'a
pas encore atteint ses buts de guerre et
l'ukraine ait dit non on lâche rien que
ces drames et je crois que kissinger à a
jeté un pavé dans la mare alors ce qu'il
a appelé la le cren à faire des
concessions territoriales je crois que
maintenant le le jeu est lancé et voilà
on va s'y opposer beaucoup mais il faut
en parler de manière
plus ouverte parce que quand on voit que
la diplomatie n'avance plus que la
russie maintenant a repris du poil de la
bête depuis qu'on est là quelques gains
militaires et que sur le long terme
soyons réalistes la l'ukraine ne peut
pas gagner une guerre militaire face à
la russie donc en tout cas l'avis de
résister plus que jusqu'à présent
les américains leur prédisent une
victoire possible et prédisent mais
soyons réalistes voit bien que ils ont
beaucoup de mal parce que c'est quand
même une supériorité malgré les
problèmes d'organisation de l'armée
russe et à une supériorité à la fois max
et d'armand de des troupes et de pas mal
d'autres choses quoi donc on le voit en
ce moment et
la belle à la réalité maintenant est
très clair le cren contrainte à des
concessions territoriales au nom du
risque de la faim dans le monde ce
serait ça finalement l'argument est ce
que ça va suffire d'après-vous virginie
hertz pour l'instant le regard se porte
surtout vers la russie puisque emmanuel
macron dire cet entretien avec vladimir
poutine à ce sujet et avoir même évoqué
l'adoption d'une résolution à l'onu qui
demain 4 très clair à la levée du blocus
du port d'odessa est-ce qu'on a les
moyens de contraindre les russes alors
contraindre certainement pas non depuis
le début on sait qu'on n'a pas les
moyens de contraindre les russes tout
simplement si la puissance nucléaire
points voilà par contre on peut faire
pression on peut essayer d' unique vous
falloir et militairement le blocus de
décembre non il mine c'est très
compliqué ce sera très compliqué à faire
et aucun allié à priori ne prendra les
risques pour le faire un militairement
c'est trop risqué la situation donc
cesser de la négociation c'est de la
contrainte vous disiez enfin vous tout à
l'heure vous avez évoqué cette fin de
guerre cette négociation qui doit enfin
arrivé entre moscou et kiev hier la
ministre française des affaires
étrangères est allé sur place et l'a dit
évidemment c'est ce qui va falloir faire
un moment donné d'ailleurs la france
maintient le canal de discussion mais
ouvrons avec les russes trop tard
mais pour le moment d'après d'hab voilà
ce que pour le moment personne n'est le
père en société et marcin dès le sommet
européen du mois de mars évoqué dans la
bouche des manuels macron cerises de
famine donc on en est conscient depuis
quasiment le début de cette guerre un
effet six mois ça n'a pas permis et cela
devrait être pire l'année prochaine
notamment par le lait la baisse des
envois d'engrais
on en vient à présent à ce traité
historique celui signé aujourd'hui entre
israël et les émirats arabes unis accord
de libre-échange deux ans à peine après
qu'ils aient établi des relations
diplomatiques écouté la ministre des
affaires étrangères du côté d'abu dhabi
nous avons signé ici à dubaï un traité
de libre-échange le premier avec un pays
arabe et c'était la ministre cette amie
israélienne des affaires étrangères et
non pas des émirats un rapprochement en
tout cas avec et les émirats arabes unis
et du coup un rapprochement avec
l'arabie séoudite géant régional qui est
évidemment dans toutes les têtes
désormais virginie herz des touches en
plus dire que quand il dans cet accord
alors c'est quasiment la levée de toutes
les bagnes et barrière d'os douanière
jeudi toutes ces 96 % ce qui fait quand
même énormément les deux pays mis sur le
fait que le commerce devrait plus que
doubler en moins 2 en moins de cinq ans
donc ce qui est énorme dans notamment
plusieurs secteurs les énergies
renouvelables et biens de consommation
le tourisme les sciences du vivant et
pour israël dubaï devrait être une
plateforme pour essayer de commencer à
rayonner plus dans la région au
moyen-orient mais de façon plus générale
en asie du sud est c'est la suite des
accords d'abraham ce qui est intéressant
quand même c'est que la presse
étrangères étaient conviés au départ à
cette grande cette signature est
finalement beaucoup de journalistes
n'ont pas pu y aller comme si finalement
il y avait une espèce d'embarras ça
arrive dans un contexte particulier la
mort de la journaliste palestinienne
shirin à boîte les morts sous les balles
de soldats israéliens
elle n'a pas eu d'impact sur cette
signature mais il semblerait qu'en tous
cas la cause palestinienne soit mise de
côté mais ça politiquement ça reste un
sujet sensible ça expliquerait en tout
cas que certains journalistes n'ait pas
pu assister à cette conférence de presse
c'est beaucoup de communication
de faire passer la pilule dans ce
contexte particulièrement tendu mais ça
montre bien que la réelle politique
quand même sa firme et que et que cette
question la question la cause
palestinienne est vraiment passé
offensive diplomatique tous azimuts
puisqu'aujourd'hui même l'ambassade
d'israël ici en france organisé une
conférence pour renforcer sa présence
sur le continent africain marie rose est
tout à fait et il faut souvent rappelé
que c'est une relation très ancienne et
qui date des années 50 et et qui a eu
son apogée dans les années 60-70 alors
très connu aussi des hauts et des bas au
gré du conflit israélo palestiennes tout
à fait de guerre jusqu'en 73 au moment
de la guerre de yom kippour
qu'il y avait à peu près de 1500
coopérants israélien il y avait un vent
d'idéalisme jeune nation israélienne va
prêter assistance aussi au jeune pays
indépendant etc et donc il ya eu cette
rupture là mais est donc la question
israël publique palestinienne et venus
occulter des connexions assez profondes
et des développements je dirais des
relations des mouvements de solidarité
qui existait pourquoi vente avec les
élites juives et les peuples africains
alors par exemple en afrique du sud
t aujourd'hui est l'un des pays qui
s'opposent le plus à israël et notamment
à l'influencé d'israël au sein de
l'union africaine et à son retour au
sein du nhs
l'union africaine avec un siège
d'observateur mais alors le passé est
très différent c'est que si on s'accorde
aujourd'hui à reconnaître que la
constitution sud africaine est l'une des
meilleures les murs et didier les plus
rêver les plus lumineuses du monde c'est
beaucoup de l influence de quelqu'un
comme albi saxe qui est un grand
constitutionnaliste
les lancer a eu beaucoup de monde elle a
eu beaucoup de compagnons de route qui
était juive des justes et africa je
pense à joe slovo et à quelqu'un d'autre
qui est dans mon panthéon personnel qui
s'appelle route faire ce qui est l
épouse de joe slovo qui était
journaliste et qui est morte a été
assassiné par les services secrets sud
africain dans un pays de la lune de
ligne de front au mozambique où était
réfugié parce que voilà et juste il ya
eu une scène extrêmement très puissante
et dynamique là bas paraît en a un aux
états unis le mouvement des droits
civiques a été extrêmement porté aussi
par des intellectuels view des
intellectuels juifs je pense aussi à les
allées compagnon de martin luther king
et juste pour dire ou einstein qui a dit
des choses extrêmement forte qui s'est
beaucoup engagée contre le racisme anti
noirs aux états unis est aussi juste un
dernier exemple c'est l'élection de
barack obama
qui soit on dit qu'il ya à peu près 78%
de juifs américains qui ont voté pour
lui malgré des accusations de assez
insidieuse qu'il était musulman pour un
musulman cash etc donc je crois que il y
a ça c'est assez occulter on le sait pas
assez et israël maintenant veut un peu
revenir à la charge puisque beaucoup de
choses ont changé depuis
quand on voit la question palestinienne
et passer à l'arrière-plan beaucoup de
pays africains et c'était la politique
de natanyahou qui n'a pas beaucoup
disons qu'il a engagé un grand mouvement
de reconnaissance de l'état d'israël
extra d'amitié avec des pays sans ouvrir
beaucoup d'ambassades contraire l'une
des rares qu'ils ont ouverte en plus de
celle qui existait c'est au rwanda et au
ghana et pour soi même on a dû en fermer
hull en amérique latine dont mais
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il y à
des préoccupations très très direct
est-ce qu'on a fini et on a fait dix
jours merci en tout cas faut arrêter
avec nous aujourd'hui merci également à
virgin hier si on se retrouve dans trois
minutes pour un nouveau journal rester
avec
[Musique]